welcome guys
hope you're well um as always
patreon that raw raw that good good
that sloppy top um hit us up
links in the description three pound a
month baby p
easy money easy money uh we were just
talking now
we decided we want to hit 10k subs on
youtube
by christmas not back by end of end of
2020 20.
so december 31st we want to be on 10 000
subscribers on youtube so if you could
help us up
help us up help us out we would be um
very appreciative
for sure for sure for sure smash that
like button as well guys oh yeah
pound that like button the algorithm the
algorithm it's all about the algorithms
yeah we need to break the algorithm boy
because it's um
it's kicking our butt at the minute um
and then obviously for you lovely um
audio listeners subscribe make sure you
get those uh
automatic downloads leave us a nice
review if you're feeling generous and um
yeah ben enjoy the fun fact of the day
so i think it's a two-part thing the fun
fact
i'd let you do your monster first these
are hard to open g
oh rubicon's been in the fridge for a
while maybe maybe
i don't know
someone looks me in my boat and just i'd
make the best gay guy
let's just put this out there i would
make the best gay guy
make the worst you'd make the worst gay
guy i'd make the worst gay girl
you wouldn't entertain like you're the
kind of guy who would resent being gay
and you're ju you're just used man to
get the nuts that you need to get
but you won't want to talk to them you
definitely don't want them staying
around afterwards
that i need to get oh you need to clap
those cheeks but you're so vex about it
and you just like shut up and get on
your knees firm shut up open your mouth
shut
shut up just do it
i'm tired of this just bust that nut and
get out
[ __ ] hell that's jokes but yeah um so
yeah the
fun fact of the day is too um
two-pronged um so did you know that flat
worms
have both male and female organs
flat worms is
a flat worm like those digestive worms i
don't know james
it's a tapeworm that is the table i
actually do know that it's a takeaway
you said tapeworm yeah um they've got
um sexual orgasms men and females
they've got both male and females that's
um
is that similar to sea horses something
like that sea horses right
it actually might be there there is an
aquatic animal yes but i can't remember
which one is i'm sure sea horses
can be male or female or something like
the males
give birth or something like that that's
a sketch that brings up they're sketchy
like that that's to be fair why is the
horse in a c
sketchy it rings a bell um anyway um
so yeah fat worms are have both male and
female organs
they engage i can't even say this with a
show face
they engage in penis fencing before
mating
what's that you know exactly what it is
tip touch
they engage in tummy sticks let me say
the tinkers
go on all right i'ma start again
flatworms have both
male and female sex organs they engage
in penis fencing
before mating in an attempt to penetrate
their opponent
and inject them with sperm the one who
succeeds
becomes the father and the one who
fertilizes becomes the mother
that's just rape
so say that again what did you say after
tommy stix what did you say after that
the
they fight tommy sticks yes so
yeah they they fight to see which one
penetrates you first
and if one of them penetrates the other
one first they just shoot
into it they just have to hold the nut
and then you're the yeah
you're the yeah and i'm the pops that's
it
nah that's that's a game
that is one of the scariest things i've
ever actually heard like if you if you
think about it
that's terrifying that's terrifying wow
that's
absolutely terrible speaking of animals
i've been obviously
you guys know i love a documentary and
i've been watching a lot of david
attenborough like i've seen loads but i
like re
i re-watch them i was watching them
again last night and i just
for those who don't know who david
attenborough is david attenborough is a
guy
the best way i think i can put it like
he's a guy that's dedicated his life to
educate the world
he is a guy that loves animals and loves
the planet he started loving animals
first and then became to love the planet
so that he does just
he does shows and documentaries about um
like the life cycle of animals and the
planet and the ecosystem etc
um so i was watching one of his
documentaries yesterday and i've been
watching it throughout like this lock
down and the pass lock down as well
and it really really is the wild out
there like
i feel like penguins have it the hardest
because
penguins go through penguins go through
it penguins go through the reason why
i feel like penguins go through is
because they are land-based animals
but they get their food from the water
they just have to fight
they have to fight it out every single
not every single day but like throughout
the three month period or whatever they
have to go in
whatever do what they need to do to feed
so
i'm thinking to myself like
i just that could never be me like do
you know what i mean
bro that could never be wait let me just
let me just get let's go out go on let
me let me get this store and give you a
bit of context
because it's it's baffling it's baffling
so obviously
penguins for those that don't know
penguins eat fish i think the anchovies
something like a lot something small
along those lines anyway
so they obviously swim out to sea to eat
there to grab their food and what they
do is
if you again if you don't know what they
do is they they swallow the fish then
they
if they get back to the land they go
meet their yat and then they vomit the
fish out so they
that so they're
and then the wife's not saying they can
eat that's how they feed um so they they
go out to sea
scramble all the fish they can eat and
then on their way back
they're either going to get attacked by
a dolphin or
a sea otter hmm do you know what i mean
and it's like
context lion you mean sila or a seal no
they get attacked by seals seals
seals that's the one seals so for
context imagine
on your day-to-day life you have to go
to a restaurant every day
to eat because you have to eat you're
hungry you have to not just you
sorry it is just you but you have to
bring the food back for the rest of your
family yeah
but you're not allowed to go hungry
you're not allowed to you ha so you have
to go every day but every time every
night on your way back
there's ten murderers on loose just man
there's just ten murderers
everywhere you just have to walk you
just have to direct me through the bits
directly through the rolex on your wrist
and just hope nothing happens
because it's literally do or die no it's
literally do or die
in the wild and it's like i don't have
the stomach for that
i don't have the stomach for that
sometimes i just want to swim bro
it's literally like you think about in
um
you know when there's like a zombie
apocalypse yeah and then man have to go
to the supermarket at some point to get
their stuff and the zombies galore
imagine it's just wednesday afternoon
and you have to go
and you're like i'm not going today i
don't you can't i'll go hungry
i'm not going today but then your
family's like
no we've got a baby and you're the baby
will die if you don't go it's like i've
been doing this every day
i'm so sick of it every day my heart
is aching i'm not putting myself through
this again today
you go you go i will stay with the you
fam penguins go through penguins the
cycle is mad because
eat um
cereal oh seals they get seals as well
killer whales killer whales eat sales
yeah yeah
um and there was one there was an
episode i was watching i think it was
yesterday two days ago
um the the seal was on like an icicle
because it was running it was literally
fighting for his life and swimming away
from these [ __ ] so what
they've got animals are probably the
smartest like
things on this earth like us aside
animals are
because they can't actually speak
they're so intuitive it's ridiculous so
what they do is let's say
um the seal was on the size of let's say
this table for example
so this table is probably about what 20
by 60. um
so let's say i c was on that obviously
the seal has been much bigger than that
but for example
so what they do is the the um whales
go towards it go towards the table and
dive under it straight away so it
creates like a wave
so that wave splashes the steel straight
away
and it [ __ ] get like it's it's wipes
it off so as soon as it swipes it off
they go for it they absolutely go for it
then i had a thought of how do they
share it
they tear it in half in it do they i've
seen it they tear the thing in half
do they they tear the ting in half do
you know what they also do as well
they play with it i know they got by the
tail and they fling it in there
this same seal he was for about 15
minutes he was going from icicle to
icicle swimming away so many there was
one point he was
he laid in high school they showed his
face he had one normal eye and one
bruised eye he had blood all down the
side of him
and it just saw this they just showed
them the well come up
bite it by its tail and drag it back
into the water and it showed it from
scene it showed it from the perspective
of the of the seal
so we saw the seal try and try and slide
hold on hold on to the eye he knew it
was done and he drapes him slowly
we just knew he died how do animals deal
with that
i've because i watched um if no one
follows this
and may if you could if you've got the
stomach for it the nature is metal
no nature as well you sent me
it's too much bro when the lions and
stuff are chasing down
like the antelope and the antelope's
just knackered
and it just gives up because it's just
too tired and then it just has to sit
there
and the lions just eat it like ass first
and this is alive just getting yammed in
agony
i'm not dealing with that i'll beg you
from kill me
please i watched one there was another
scene um
where wolves were chasing i think there
were yaks
in like alaska or something um so the
walls are [ __ ] smart as well they
surrounded the whole thing and then
obviously the yak started running away
but they're obviously just trying to go
for one yak they caught one
and about seven of them attacked it but
it was like three of three yachts behind
them so
the first one darted past the yacht they
didn't care about the bredrin they
didn't care about the sister so
there's a second one as well warped ran
past it by hit a few of the wolves
so i'm thinking okay you're trying to
back you're trying to back the beef
you're trying to support your boy
gang the last yak bumped
into the back of the other yak so this
yak can topple over
so so he could just die it's one of the
most brutal things i've ever seen 10
seconds ago
we were eating together bro survival of
the fittest
i could if you're bitter than me i will
trip you i couldn't be an animal
family i'm so happy i'm a human being
we're so lucky
we have no idea if you guys have never
it's on netflix and it's on like bbc or
for those that are in that are abroad
just watch it on youtube or something
it's so fascinating like bro we are so
lucky we're human beings are not animals
we are we are we are
i would be dead within a day long it's
long i think is what it's long for
everyone there was um
as one there's a david attenborough show
called i want to say it's called the
hunt
okay there's a series called the hunt
fantastic
yeah my favorite dave at a show today
fantastic there's a bit in there and
it's um
talking about like lions and hyenas and
obviously lions
run hyenas literally just like literally
like a lion king is how it actually is
yeah yeah um it was mad that episode was
like this is the like this is the lion
king they actually stole the plot from
real life
this is the linking plot from real life
but um
there's a scene in there where there's
there's two like teenage lions these two
adolescent male lions they're brothers
big man the life of a lion is actually
long
because their whole life if you're a
male your life is tough yeah and if
you're a female your life is even more
tough
but if you're a male you're born so
let's say it's me and my brother
we're born we grow up and when you're a
teenager
you have to start hunting for yourself
these two lions
hunt for themselves and they think
they're the tits basically
bro there's this one point where one of
the lions just
wanders off i think i've seen this yeah
fam he wanders off into hyena territory
okay i think i've seen this
and they start picking on him and he's
by himself and he kind of just like
shoves them off or whatever from before
you know there's like 25 hyenas
i've seen this he can't take him out
i'll take them all yeah i don't think i
took one breath in this entire
four-minute scene
it's intense it's in you thinking oh
he's had it yeah and just like you said
with the seal with the bruise and that
yeah he's got cuts on his scratches and
he's
he's fending for his life yeah and these
hyenas are trying to eat him big man
they're trying to eat yeah i know
i was terrified i was terrified and then
i don't know his brother
did yeah brother was the clear
clear saver yeah all it took was one
more line to shut the thing down
the brother came in and they went on a
back-to-back thing and murked all the
hype i remember
it was like a movie it was like a movie
i was thinking how many months were they
stationed here to get this shot yeah oh
because
that was an unbelievable scene yeah and
um i was thinking rod the wild is truly
wild
the wild is truly the wild because it's
long out here
i could never be a wild animal i
wouldn't survive
i wouldn't survive a day knowing my
personality i wouldn't survive
if i was as a animal i'm dead within a
day
some of the stuff that transpires these
things is just
it's not worth it those are the real
streets it's not worth those are the
real streets
i don't know how they manage but um
fun fact did you know that um
blue planet david attenborough's blue
planet yeah on imdb is the highest rate
of show of all time
say mothers oh wow i really like blue
planet
i love blue i really like blue planet i
love blue planet how anyone can watch
blue planet and
be fearless of sharks is is beyond me
how anyone could be not afraid of your
biggest fear in it you hate sharks and
what you said about the killer whales
killer whales terrify me orcas
terrify me how anyone can just be okay
with
with with that being a thing i don't
think i
okay how he got people to
record this i i don't know what pitch he
would have given because
i can't see a whale you know what yeah i
can't see a whale sorry to cut you off
you know when people are just venturing
in alaska and [ __ ] yeah or canada or
niagara falls whatever
and they see a nice breach and the whale
pops up like
the boat's here and the whale pops here
and the tails above them and they're all
taking pictures like wow it was amazing
like the whale came up that's my worst
nightmare i could never
see you i will scream like you've never
seen him scream yes
my throat would tear i would be so
terrified i could not see a whale
there's a video there's actually a video
on nature's metal where these man got
eaten by a whale by accident
so obviously whales don't eat people
yeah
these men are kayaking they're kayaking
actually my phone's like my instagram is
occupied where's your phone
go to nature's metal that's and then
dash me the thing i'll show you it
these men are kayaking this whale's
hunting krill
and obviously they open their mouth to
just get as many crit as possible fam
he comes above the water takes the kayak
in his mouth
i would even though they survived i
would die of a heart attack oh they
survived they survived because the
the world spat him out he didn't want
that okay but he just took him fam
he took him oh my
god let me find it here it is here it is
where's the kayak this yellow one here
so there's a kayaking this is the other
one here what's the other one
[Music]
what it's a real thing oh what what nah
they didn't even show it
hang on no it's not finished you should
watch the reel click the ring oh watch
reels
sorry bro
i don't know what's happening with this
imagine you've been in that kayak
imagine you've been in that kayak
you just got eaten by a whale let me see
that again
bro he scooped them up
he scooped them up oh my god
if hold on wait let me finish watching
again
bro if i'm obviously okay context guys
so in this video there's there's a red
kayak
there's a yellow kayak and there's
someone else filming so i'm assuming
they're on another kayak or they're on
land
um and it's far and they're just
chilling
chilling
chilling kayaking paddling or whatever
and there's birds around him
all of a sudden the yellow king that's
in the far corner on the edge of the
screen
gets yam out yamaha by a whale but
that's what it's that's what he said he
doesn't show him spitting out with it
just shows that bit
i'm thinking if i'm the ma being the
yellow kayak aside
because i know i'm dead already yeah my
heart even though he spat me out
my heart wouldn't take it oh fam like
i'll be face down floating in the water
i'll be facing
oh my god i don't think you know
i just don't i don't think you
understand what i would do i wouldn't
stay to see what happened
i'll be gone if i was in that red kayak
i'm gone i'm gone now i can't be next
nah nah nah nah i don't care if it was
an accident
this you're not taking me this is why i
don't understand why people are so
comfortable in the ocean i just don't
get it
how can you be there are so many
dangerous things out there
people just aren't taking serious people
aren't taking the ocean seriously
seriously they're not giving it the
respect it deserves
there's more of them than they are of us
bro anything can
is on site in the ocean it is constantly
on site
it's tom and jerry 24 7 bro
oh i could never see a whale i could
never see you away i would die i've
never seen one now and i don't think i
ever watched i don't ever want to see it
i could
never see a whale i'm not interested in
it i don't ever i understand how
magnificent it is
but that's i'm too scared
i'm too scared like it's not worth it
it's not worth it the pros do not wear
out outweigh the cons for me not even
like killer whales like
massive those massive blue ones i could
never see a blue whale or that was
probably i think
they said that was a sperm whale maybe
um any huge well i can't see
i could never kill a whale millions
percent can't see because it's
essentially a giant shark yeah
people make out like killer whales like
shamu and all that is there some plating
it's a giant shark it's huge and it's
the most it's the smart it's smarter
than a shark i know
they're they're entertaining they
orchestrate they're hunting groups
i know you explained it to me already
and that people know this and they're
just [ __ ] around the water
so yeah back to the point of i don't
know what david attenborough sold these
men to be their
videographers and whatnot and producers
because you couldn't pay me enough money
to do it no you couldn't i'm not
doing it never not flying to alaska
being airborne just above the water to
catch
a [ __ ] tale of uh to catch a video of
a tale of a whale nah bro i would scream
nah i would scare everything there's
certain things there's certain animals
out there that make you realize that
we're insignificant
oh for sure we're human beings are so
insignificant and we've
grown we've learned to lie to ourselves
and convince ourselves
until [ __ ] happens that goes down and
you're just like oh we're nothing
we are we are absolutely the world is so
much more bigger than us
there's like a crocodile will have you
have you seen oh my god this is when
this was
either two weeks ago or by the time this
comes out i'll probably be like two
weeks ago
um in florida
yeah the massive alligator the most
hench alligator anyone's ever seen
just on road i've never seen an
alligator so far from the floor
period his shoulders were in fact and he
was
swaying man was he had weight to him
these my hench sam i was actually
watching another podcast where they
actually brought up this clip of this
huge ass alligator walk in and
apparently alligators and crocodiles can
run
up to like 22 23 miles an hour run
run that's faster than usain bolt uh
you're saying bucks 27
oh so only if i just if it was them
versus us
usa is the only one that will get away
the rest of us are done for
for the first 30 meters that we're done
for that was the biggest crocodile i've
ever seen
and i'm not i couldn't see that there's
certain crocodiles out there that make
that one look like a baby
these there's like a like i think it's a
nile crocodile
these egyptian dons they're like 300
years old
and they are gigantic
i've heard they're like 20 20 feet and
they're not extinct like they're
they're about on road no they're on road
they just live in these murky waters
they live in in the nile they live in
africa family and they just take down
big animals huge animals they take them
down for breakfast
did you also know fun fact
apparently there's never ever been a
recorded case
of a crocodile dying from old age
um
that's very interesting i don't i'm
pretty sure it's a crocodile yeah
there's never ever been a recorded case
of a crocodile dying from old age so
they're from
like natural causes natural causes not
unnatural cause so like fighting
fighting um yeah being eaten by another
crocodile or something like that
uh maybe like freezing to death
something like that never have they died
from
natural causes just old age never
they're old family oh wow crocodiles
live for hundreds on hundreds of years
and they can go
i'm pretty sure they can go like a year
without eating
oh wow because they managed to just stay
completely still
and shut down their body lower their
heart rate everything
and put themselves into just like a
hibernative state
until something comes along no i could
never see a croc i could ah
i'd quote my eyes out if i saw a
crocodile when i went to disney world we
stayed
in this uh we rented out this house
in florida and it was um literally like
where the alligator was
there was a massive lake just outside
our house it was so nice
i saw an alligator it was a small one
but i [ __ ] saw one from your yard or
what's my yard
looking in the lake i saw alligator
that's not small that's not a small idea
if you can see it from your yard it's in
the
that's not oh bro i was like nah we're
done here
what more is there to see get me back to
england immediately
i couldn't i couldn't that's that's a
fear of mine
some people are brave too brave wait
where did they get off
i don't know anyway let's get to the
show
thanks for indulging us guys um oh
thank you so fun request
of the day cool so fan request hey guys
love the podcast
i have a topic for you what do you think
about friends with benefits
can it work can it work without someone
catching feelings
can you hang out with them as well or
should you bang and go
love to know what you think and any past
experiences
um that's two pronged because if you're
saying friends with benefits then
banging and going is it's not a friend
of ben's not a friend with benefits it's
just something
that's just a thing if you've got a
friend with benefits then you actually
have to speak and stuff blah blah to be
their friend
um can it work without one of them
catching feelings it depends on how much
how much you [ __ ] them it depends on how
much how much you [ __ ] that no but you
know what i mean you know what i mean
like
you know what i mean yeah yeah and it
also depends on
um how how many times you've liked them
how many
it depends on what what she looks like
it kind of depends on what kind of
friendship you have
as well tight it's never gonna work
i don't think that's going to work yeah
if you're i'm saying if you're tight
tight
basically the only thing stopping you
from being a relationship is the sex
yeah so now you've crossed off that
you're interested in a relationship so
it has to be someone who's not really a
friend
kind of a friend i don't know i've never
have i ever had like a a friend of
benefits
i'm trying to think i don't think
i have no
i've never had a friend with benefits
that's just like oh we're boys but
we bang like i've never
not in that kind of context anyway nah
not in that con i've never had like a
friend
who then like we started to become
like we just started having sex but
we're still so we're still socially
friends like
that would never happen i've never had
that that could never happen i don't
think it can work
it can't work and plus it will actually
deep it down yeah yeah i think you know
what is
for me i think the concept of friends
with benefits
is a really outdated concept now
because like the premise of a friend of
benefits is two people
who don't want to be in a relationship
but they want someone
who they can just [ __ ] yeah but with
tinder and stuff like that you can get
that now anyway yeah yeah you if you
just want to get someone who's just a
beat
you can find that yeah and like
even without dating apps and stuff like
the social etiquette around
being it's more um it's less round upon
now to just be open and say
like i'm just looking for sex like it's
not hard to say that to someone now
without them being offended you can say
hey look
i'm not really looking i'm looking i'm
literally looking just for someone to
have fun with and that's it you don't
really need a friend
yeah um of the opposite sex to do that
for you now
they don't need it it's not worth it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's not worth it i don't feel like i
don't feel like it can work
especially if they're actually your
friend like it's
it just boils it's gonna get sticky
because
it's not about necessarily catching
feelings it probably more of a case of
a situation will occur let's say you're
with the friend
platonically in a sense in a platonic
scene like let's say you've gone
to the cinema or like she's chilling at
yours or something like that you're
chilling out of hers
yeah and someone else holds you and be
like oh come through i'm trying to smell
like there's another thing that's trying
to hold you blah blah
i feel like that's so awkward to talk
about considering they are actually your
friend yeah
that it's just not gonna it's just not
gonna be so i'm saying you're in a
relationship yeah emotion will get in
the way yeah because you're in a
relationship yeah
like when you have a friend with
benefits like you said like you can't
just
have another ting shout on your phone
and be like cool i'm gonna go link this
other thing now
like safe you can't have that because
they're also your friend yeah that's
what a relationship is
is a friend who you you smash that's
what a girlfriend is yeah
um so yeah i don't think you can work at
all man it doesn't i think it's
pointless
it is i like the concept like the first
bang
i'm sure is live the first one probably
will be live i'm sure it banks
but after that it's just like what are
we doing here man after the nut the
literal post not clarity
oh dear i would be terrified i'll be
terrified i would not
i think i would think about the post not
clarity before i've known and think i
can't
stop [ __ ] we have to continue [ __ ]
now like because i can't go through this
post not clarity i can't it's not worth
it it's not working i would
overthink it so much i'm not even an
overthinker but in that situation
like as soon as i've knighted i'd feel
like we have to have a talk
you know what i mean
that would give me stress that would
give me anxiety i don't need that i
don't think anyone needs that
so friends with benefits i don't think
it works i think the idea of it works
and
obviously the way it sounds works but
you truly can't be friends
you good i just splashed up my nose oh
[ __ ]
yeah you truly truly truly can't be
friends um
whilst you're [ __ ] her or him so yeah
yeah man because it just goes in the it
just goes in the way of a relationship
like it goes from
cool um we're friends
decent now we're having sex decent so
we're friends who have sex
cool um you now still have to be
respectful of my feelings
sounds like a girlfriend i'd rather you
not tell me about anyone else you're
sleeping with
sounds like a girlfriend that does sound
like a girlfriend and just like
and now you like i don't know it's just
a girlfriend
just girlfriend like you're my
girlfriend like it just seems
it seems dumb and now if we stop having
sex
we're probably gonna stop talking all
together girlfriend
girlfriend um yeah so yeah
it's weird do you know what's funny
obviously in um i think was was it
which episode was it no yeah yeah
actually it
i think it was um the episode we did
with bella when we spoke about the jump
off thing
the chick from new york and i think the
am i the [ __ ] we did
was it was it that same one we did um
the guy wanted to
do a round trip to new york and blah
blah blah i was just thinking about it
was the same
yeah i was thinking that as you were
saying that it literally just dawned on
me really yeah
i thought you did i was surprised you
didn't say that when you were saying
that because i was thinking oh imagine
if it was the same yet
um but then in context it's obviously
not but um
yeah that'll be funny um boy
that is that is wild
that jump off thing was funny that jump
off thing was funny and i found that
that better episode was good man because
i don't know it was nice to actually
have a chance to just say
cool like not even just like discussion
topics
yeah but cool like this is what i think
girls think is this true
this is how i think girls think is this
true yes or no yeah yeah and a lot of
times like no
um that whining with the hard-on thing
breath of fresh air i was like oh wow
thank god like my teenage years aren't
ruined
um speaking of whining
this is funny i ain't had one in a while
i haven't obviously haven't had a wine
in a while
i was listening to um when the whisky
album dropped yeah the other week yeah i
was listening to some of the tracks and
it just
pictured me back to my old mining days
yeah and i was thinking about like
from an outsider's perspective yeah
whining is
if you're an alien right yeah and you
come down
and you you calm down and you and like
you're just like spectating for the day
yeah you're just a fly on the wall
in humans and you don't know what humans
are about yeah like
whining as a concept is so bizarre talk
to me
it's two people of opposite sex yeah and
like
it's just like a um
so uh how to explain it right have you
seen the film year one
no so year one um
is jack black and michael cecera it's a
comedy movie right okay they've got
cavemen and stuff okay
i think i spoke to you about it before
so they're cavemen and there's a point
where they're all dancing that the whole
village is like dancing around the fire
and then like it's like ritual where the
women will dance around the fire
and then the men who want to smash those
women will come and dance
up next to them and just like
savagely like grab them by the hair and
take them back to the tent okay
but that's obviously caveman that's
their mating style yeah
whining is basically that like it's a
matter of woman mate
and they just do some mating dance where
they're like
rubbing their genitals against each
other yeah yeah in a very sexual manner
yeah and it's so sexual yet i'm having
to ask bella like is it eternal is it
weird if a guy gets a hard on when
you're doing that
but if like an alien sorry i'd be like
what is this
what what is this like do you mind even
know each other
and where does it go from here yeah um
but then i was thinking
about like the different types of wines
okay and like someone
tagged us the other day um
on tick tock actually oh you wouldn't
see this but yeah someone tagged us on
tick tock and was like
oh it was a girl doing like a little
skit on like the different
types of wines that a guy will do and it
was all like
the link the lean back thing and the
hiking
and the dagger thing and all these
things that guy would do but so funny
the day before that when i was listening
to the wizkid thing yeah i was thinking
all the wines a girl does
okay and i was thinking about like the
different
the different things that are actually
so funny that girls probably don't
have any idea about yeah and there's
obviously like so you know you've got
your
um so here's the different ones that i
came up with in my head i actually wrote
them down yeah okay
so actually i'm excited to know you've
named them
there's something so first this isn't
just a girlfriend but this is
you know those eye contact wines so i'm
here
dancing by myself she's there dancing by
herself out
and then we're just doing a little yeah
and this facial expression
[Laughter]
me
and she's just there like stush my life
keeps swaying
the whole time we're getting one step
closer
every time yeah every time and then
we're just there like nice to know just
like whoa
until she [ __ ] turns around yeah
you're like
now we're whining yeah and then you got
um
obviously you've got like a standard
like a decent wine yeah where it's just
straight up um matching rhythm
everything yeah all good perfect nothing
enough to say
those are the ones where you're getting
hard on and she's essential with it
then you've got the yachts that are
above
and you think this is going to be a wine
and she comes at you
and she moves on you like she's trying
to solve a rubik's cube on your dick
and she's just there and you're trying
to you're trying to find your favorite
you're trying to follow your fantasies
and their hair is flickering and it
scratches your
fan hair is sharp it scratches your nose
and you're just there like okay
and you're trying to slow it down like
okay
she's trying to slow it up
slow the [ __ ] baby and then she's going
off and she thinks
this is sexy in her she's thinking i'm
sexy
i'm killing this bro ahead i'm killing
the worst thing
ever i know exactly worst team ever
and i was actually howling to myself
thinking these guys think they're
nice that's jokes a concept is
let's say when you die would you ever
wanna be able to
view your life back like
there are times where bella and i are at
yard just chilling
and chatting and we're just [ __ ]
laughing
right and i'm like there's no one else
that's going to see this
this is never going to happen again and
obviously it's a memory for us but i'm
probably never not going to remember it
in 20 years
but i'd love to i know what i mean i
know what you mean like um
i would love yeah i would love someone
to see like uh
just kind of like how this is like
imagine your life being a podcast
and someone's just watching it or like a
movie like your life's a movie
and they're just you just they're just
watching these actual like obviously
they're funny bits
to talk about but they someone could
actually
see it see everything they could see in
live uh live action that would be so
live because yeah there's certain bits
in my life that
maybe weren't even funny at the time
yeah if someone could see them through a
lens
as it's going out hilarious also another
thing um
do you ever feel like you know when you
have like random outbursts
and like you have do you ever have like
random conversations with yourself all
the time
do you ever feel like those are your
true feelings hence the reason why
you're having these random outbursts
some random conversations
what do you mean so let's say for
example
you let's say for example me and a girl
have had an argument
um let's say over what's up or something
if you had an argument the night before
over what's up or whatever
and let's say i have to drive to a
destination let's say i'm driving to
work
but on that drive to work i'm having the
argument in my head with that with the
girl
yep knowing my head out loud with the
girl and the way the conversation is
going i'm obviously right
yeah yeah i feel like that's because
that's my true feeling that's the way i
feel about everything yeah
and obviously that's a very specific
example it doesn't have to be a fact
that it's an argument and it happened
the night before
i could be thinking of something random
that's happened
time ago and it just comes up and i just
be like x y and zebra
i say i say it out loud to myself and i
feel like is that because i feel that
way
i know what you mean you know what i
mean yeah yeah yeah it's a very weird
thought because
it happened to me i can't remember what
i was thinking about or what i said
but what after i said i was thinking is
that because that's how i truly feel
but it wasn't something that happened
like yesterday will happen today it was
very very random don't you think it's
interesting how um
speaking of like argument and stuff how
someone else is having empathy for
someone else can
be like a disarming effect on your own
opinions so like when you say like say
if you you've just had an argument or
you've just
you know you're gonna have an argument
with like your girlfriend or something
yeah yeah
and you play out the argument in your
head on the drive over and you're
you're you're literally arguing getting
angry
yeah in this imaginary argument yeah and
you're like you've decided like you're
solidified like no i
am vex yeah like i'm vex about this yeah
yeah but just enough
to hear how they feel about the
situation
is enough for me to not be vex anymore
sometimes okay and it's just like
but i don't want to not be vex because i
know deep down in the car 10 minutes ago
i was vex about this regardless or in my
head it was like
regardless of what you were whatever you
have to say to defend yourself
i am vex about this and that is just
this is where my opinion is
then as soon as i hear it come out of
your mouth and i see your expression
yeah and i see pain from you yeah i'm
like
i can't be fixed about it yeah and it's
weird because it's like
do i truly feel how i felt in the car
yeah or do i truly feel
is this how i truly feel no that's not
how you choose i feel like you truly
feel how you felt in the car but you're
just reacting to what you've seen
your body's just adapted and adjusted to
what you've seen it's true but then
again is that healthy
because is that is that a true
resolution then if you're only reacting
to how that
other person's being is that at all when
you come to a resolution
at the end of the argument have you
truly resolved it within yourself
because it's only it's only squashed
because
you feel bad or whatever yeah yeah i
decided not to argue yeah
i decided to argue because you cared
more about than not being upset than you
did about arguing
stuff like that is that i i uh often
wonder about
hmm that makes sense that is very
interesting yeah very interesting do you
want to do um am i the [ __ ]
of course okay
mommy and soul to die oh god
actually sometimes i think they're long
but they're not that long
right
am i the [ __ ] been watching the
podcast for a long time and i love it
but i wanted to get your thoughts on
something so from
early high school i was talking to a
girl every year
we got together but never went all the
way at the same time i was good friends
with her brother
and he was part of the group i moved
away
and on one visit back home me and the
girl met up for drinks
and got a hotel together start again
stopping
paying attention no i was until i heard
this hotel thing so i need to get a bit
more
i need to hear it again just before i
like right right so let me i mean
let me re-up i'm not reading it again
so you said like four sentences bro so
the guy um was used to okay [ __ ]
ridiculous
right so from early on in high school i
was talking to a girl
yeah every year we got together but we
never went all the way
yeah at the same time i was good friends
with her brother
and he was part of the friendship group
i moved away
and on a single visit back home me and
the girl met up for drinks and we got a
hotel
and things happened we kept in touch
however
nothing really happened after that
myself and her
brother have been boys since and
although everyone in the group
knows i slept with his sister he never
knew four years on
we were on a night out and we were all
very drunk
i pulled my friend aside and decided in
an intoxicated state
i would finally tell him what happened
he didn't take it well
at all and we haven't spoke since this
was two weeks ago
do you think i did the right thing by
telling him
how would you guys have acted in the
situation um
i feel like you probably only told him
because
the rest of the clique knew if the rest
of the clique didn't know
ignorance is bliss do you know what i
mean yeah because
the only i feel like because of the fact
that the rest of the rest of your your
friendship group knew
you've probably felt a way that or maybe
one of them might slip up and tell him
so your best defense is to slip up and
tell him yourself
and i feel like yes you may have thought
you did the right thing at the time
and obviously now you guys aren't
talking or whatever but i just feel like
it was
it was a you shouldn't have said it but
within the same breath i don't think you
should have [ __ ] him anyway
it's a tough one as soon as when i was
reading it and it was like oh
i pulled him aside in an intoxicated
state and stuff like that my initial
thing was like you idiot
what are you doing but then it's like
again like you said like everyone in the
group knew
apart from him and you smashed his
sister and like for me
this is a bisexual thing by the way why
would it be a bisexual thing fun
what are you talking about fam hold on
hold on hold on because you said
my man my man slept with his sister
first of all how is that bisexual so why
is he telling
right the situation is is me and you man
yeah i've slept with your sister yeah
four years ago
janos rem knows tobe's nose i obviously
know you don't know
oh so so the initiative was irrelevant
then what was the initiative we're
talking about how she
was seeing this guy every year for us
that was that was irrelevant oh that was
relevant then
yeah it was just content okay okay so
basically yeah long story short okay so
that's it
okay okay okay okay okay okay um and
obviously yeah wanting to know if it was
a right thing so all
all of our boys know you don't know that
i've smashed your sister but it was four
years ago now
but you went for a drink and got a hotel
me and her went for a drink we got a
telly like it wasn't just a nice
accident it's arms house
it's arm's house of course he's of
course i'm not going to speak to you
again
fair play do you know what i mean not me
per se in the heat at the moment
he didn't explain whether because
obviously he gave that the beginning
like our
him and the sister were always seeing
each other for years before that
i don't know if the brother knew that is
an important note to make if the brother
knew that or not
true because if you had no idea that me
and your sister even chatted
and then you find out that four years
ago i got a hotel with her and we banged
arm's house obviously that's scraps arms
house but what
it's not really arm's house because
you're entitled to do what you want so
we should you know what i mean but it's
like
it's weird not having to be told
especially my sister i'm not even yeah
do you know what i mean yeah that's
that's that's mad it's not arms house
but it's it's a mind [ __ ]
it's an absolute mind fight yeah you'd
have to look at me different
yeah like you said earlier yeah you'd
have to look at me like what are you
telling me yeah what are you actually
telling me right now why are you telling
me now yeah yeah yeah why haven't she
told me
i'm getting vex thinking about it yeah
yeah she's weird bro it's weird
i really don't know i don't know if he's
that's a tough one this is probably one
of the first ones i've ever thought
where i literally cannot say if you that
i saw or not i don't
i don't think you are an artist for
saying it you can't be an article for
telling
him i think you're just you're just an
[ __ ] for
you're an [ __ ] for hiding it for so
long you're also for not
i think the sister the sibling and
that person that the individual
themselves are the [ __ ] for
hiding it in the first place and like
telling all the the group
you know what i think i think the whole
thing boils down
he's got if he if he reads this i need
him to message us again
and tell us whether the brother
knew that from all those years before
the day that you slept with her
that you were seeing his sister on and
off for three years prior because if i
was
if you knew that i was seeing your
sister from time
and then i moved away for a year then
when i moved back me and your sister
went on a date and said like
if you expected yeah i don't need to
tell you yeah yeah yeah because now it's
a separate matter like you
you are aware that i'm doing a thing
well i have done a thing with your
sister before
regardless if you've ever slept together
report you know that me and your sister
are a subject matter now as soon as
you're aware of that
and you're clearly cool with it anything
that ever happens after that i don't
need to tell you about it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so it's very important to find out
whether the brother knew
that you and his sister had anything
going on or not yeah from the from the
jump
from the jump because yeah it makes a
massive massive massive difference to
the whole story
otherwise it just sounds like you were
sneaking around with his sister
that's literally what it sounds like
yeah you're sneaking around and then
obviously the ho that
none of that is okay yeah none of that
is okay
so yeah please oh yeah this is we're
going to have to put this one on pause
on pause and
send us a message so we can find out we
didn't know if he knew
anything about the sister and if he did
then
you are actually a bit of an [ __ ] for
telling him because he didn't need to
know he didn't need to know that
yeah he didn't need to know like what
for what point purpose were you telling
him then
if he already knew that you was to do a
thing with a sister back in the day for
what purpose were you going to tell him
as well in a drunken state you thought
oh i feel bad not telling that smash
your sister the other year
like leave it that's scraps leave it
that's unnecessary scraps yeah like why
are you telling me this yeah yeah so
then you are the [ __ ]
yeah um yeah context matters i guess
yeah so anyway
let's wrap it up but yeah i'm intrigued
to find out so am i okay
peace